in diesen minuten entscheidet sich das
schicksal von rbb-intendantin patricia
schlesinger der rundfunkrat der
öffentlich rechtlichen anstalt tag es
geht um die modalitäten des ausscheidens
der zurückgetretenen intendantin steht
auch eine sofortige abberufung im raum
sprich eine fristlose kündigung wenn es
nach den mitarbeitern des rbb ging wohl
eine angebrachte lösung
geld zurück ins programm bloß nicht
weiter so rbb mitarbeiter protestieren
lautstark vor dem haus des rundfunks in
berlin und sind vor allem eins wütend
der grund die skandale rund um die ex
rbb-intendantin patricia schlesinger die
mitarbeiter machen ihrem ärger
ordentlich luft man jetzt hört dass
andere sogar noch boni dafür bekommen
haben dass es freie mitarbeiter
eingespart worden dass programme
weggefallen sind sendung weggefahren
sind dann macht einen das schon ziemlich
sauer ich das ist die erste möglichkeit
für die belegschaft den protest den wir
ja schon intern hatten nach außen zu
tragen was für mich absolut die
alarmglocken läuten lassen als es zum
ersten mal thema wurde während
gleichzeitig am programm gespart wird
nicht erinnern mich auch dass die
intendanten ex-intendant in gott sei
dank mal gesagt hat
wir haben hier gespart und wirklich bis
es knirschte während überall gespart und
jetzt bleibt uns nichts anderes übrig um
auch mal am programm zu sparen und wenn
man das jetzt so sieht wofür das geld
verprasst wurde dann ist das ja wohl
alles lüge die aufgebrachten
angestellten haben an den rundfunkrat
des rbb und die sondersitzung zur causa
schlesinger klare forderungen wir
fordern dass für die zukünftigen
geschicke dieses hauses die belegschaft
gehört wird und eingebunden wird also
ich habe vor dem grund von greven an
bord ich wirklich dass sie wirklich
endlich mal aufwachen und das ganze
ausmaß dieses dilemmas hier begreifen
und wirklich die eine fristlose
kündigung aussprechen der rbb er steht
vor einer zerreißprobe
wir haben vorhin darüber berichtet sie
haben die bilder gesehen von
protestierenden mitarbeitern des rbb
also die eigenen mitarbeiter des
rundfunks berlin-brandenburg geld zurück
ins programm hatten sie gefordert stoppt
den filz boni zurückzahlen bloß nicht
weiter so jetzt die eilmeldung es geht
nicht weiter so der rbb rundfunkrat hat
die intendantin patricia schlesinger
gefeiert eine einzigartige entwicklung
in der ard die skandal intendantin ist
mit sofortiger wirkung abberufen dafür
stimmten 22 von 23
rundfunkräten bei einer krisensitzung
damit wird formal die vertragsauflösung
in die wege geleitet und nach
bild-informationen hat sich frau
schlesinger auch nicht gegen ihre
abberufung gewährt und auch keine
abfindung gefordert dass also das
dramatische ende einer karriere im
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk ein
beispielloser vorgang in der ard
[Musik]